vienne le voir les stades sont pleins
aux états unis à l'occasion de cette
coupe du monde de football pour autant
les américains ne se passionnent pas
pour cette compétition c'est le paradoxe
d'ailleurs il faut dire qu'en amérique
sport égale business et que le football
tel que nous le pratiquons ne permet à
aucun sportif américain de faire fortune
comme c'est le cas dans le basket ou le
football américain d'ailleurs reportage
patrice romedenne scènes de la vie
quotidienne dans les rues de new york
un rectangle grillagée une surface
approximative et une horloge de fortune
en dépit des apparences
au final la tactique et ça joue sérieux
le basketball et aux etats-unis le sport
roi surtout en cette période de l'année
où l'on vit au rythme des playoffs le
tournoi final du championnat et le
football dans tout cela et bien c'est
tout de même le deuxième sport le plus
populaire du pays
un américain sur six avoue le pratiquer
et la coupe du monde ne peut qu'attiser
cet ange je regarde la coupe du monde à
la télévision et ça me plaît ça me donne
encore plus envie de bouger au basket
comme au foot tu vas tu viens tu dois
maîtriser le ballon
la seule différence c'est qu'au foot tu
le fais avec ses pieds imaginez que ce
simple match de quartier et sponsorisé
ici quand il s'agit de basket ont
investi sans compter on mise sur la
jeunesse avide de réussir par le sport
alors pourquoi pas par le football tout
simplement parce que les dollars ils
sont plus rares les universités
proposent des bourses scolaires au
basketteur mais pas aux footballeurs si
tu es un bon joueur de basket
l'université de repères elle te paie des
études elle te permet de tenter une
carrière professionnelle c'est pour ça
que le basket et le baseball sont
populaires le foot on aime bien mais tu
verras pas beaucoup de flair pas
beaucoup d'oiry jouer il n'y a pas
d'argent à prendre
les universités sont en effet la clé du
système sportif américain avant de faire
un geste
elles attendent peut-être la renaissance
du championnat professionnel de football
les etats unis l'ont promis pour avril
95 en échange de l'attribution de la
coupe du monde
riesch